Arpajon Athis-Mons Bondoufle
Chilly-Mazarin
Corbeil-Essonnes Dourdan Draveil
Épinay-sous-Sénart étampes Évry
Courcouronnes Fleury-Mérogis
Gif-sur-Yvette Grigny Juvisy-sur-Orge
Les Ulis Massy Saint-Germain-lès-Corbeil
Saint-Michel-sur-Orge Saint-Jean
Sainte-Geneviève-des-Bois
Savigny-sur-Orge Vigneux ou
Viry-Châtillon
ceci n'est malheureusement pas un cours
de géographie et sonyenne mais la liste
non exhaustive des communes de mon
département qui ont été touchées par les
émeutes
derrière le drame du décès de Naël
Merzouk est la nécessaire enquête qui
doit s'en suivre rien d'excuse les
violences les dégradations et les
pillages qui ont eu lieu dans toute la
France rien d'excuse les dégâts humains
moraux matériels et financiers rien
n'excuse enfin les attaques répétées
contre des institutions qui sont le
ciment de notre République
j'ai en effet une pensée toute
particulière pour les élus locaux et des
agents publics sur le pont jour et nuit
qui ont vu leur mairie être endommagée
comme celle de Dourdan pour les enfants
qui ont vu leurs écoles être saccagées
comme celle de Viry-Châtillon pour les
habitants d'Éric Courcouronnes et leur
maison de quartier et pour l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens qui ont vu leurs
équipements leur service de transport et
leur commerce du quotidien est dégradé
et détruit
nous avons vu des pompiers encerclés
avoir peur des policiers municipaux
municipaux assiégés certains élus être
agressés et d'autres éteindre les
incendies extincteurs toujours à portée
de main dans le coffre
à l'aune de ces réalités il nous faut
nous poser des bonnes questions et tirer
de ses événements tragiques des
enseignements pour nos territoires et
notre jeunesse il est de notre
responsabilité de prendre le temps du
débat démocratique d'échanger avec
l'ensemble des acteurs de nos quartiers
afin d'éviter tout avant aveuglement
malheureux la gravité de ces événements
ne doit être ni ignoré ni minimiser le
coût inédite se dégradation parfaitement
mise en lumière par ma collègue
Françoise Ferrat rendait nécessaire le
dépôt rapide d'un projet de loi je salue
à ce titre le recours aux ordonnances
qui plutôt qu'une rédaction prise dans
l'urgence laissera le temps à l'état de
mettre en oeuvre un plan adéquate et
permettra de consulter largement les
représentants des principales victimes
l'accompagnement de chacun doit être
notre priorité ce projet de loi répond à
cette impératif j'appelle de mes vœux
une mobilisation forte de notre
institution sur cette question mes chers
collègues les causes et les conséquences
de ce déchaînement de violence dans nos
territoires devront être étudiés et
questionnés tout comme le plan de
reconstruction une mission sénatoriale
d'enquête ou l'information me semblent
ainsi tout à fait approprié plus qu'une
reconstruction matérielle et financière
certes éminemment nécessaire et urgente
j'espère que notre démocratie
transformera la conflictualité brûlante
de ses émeutes en un puissant ferment
permettant de rebâtir des fondations
solides et républicaines dans nos
communes des fondations où le dialogue
apaisé trouvera toute sa place et où les
symboles de notre République
continueront d'être des lieux de
rassemblement plutôt que de destruction